Who is the god like Yahweh the
god of wrath the god
of Mercy The God Who
reaches down to unworthy people.
Well, good morning again beloved. It is a great to be
together worshiping the Lord with our
lives as long as well as how we sing and
praise together. If I haven't met you
yet. Please come say hello to me. I'd love to meet you. I love being
a pastor not just a preacher. And so I'd love to engage and
interact with you if I can we're nearing the end of
our journey through the Old Testament Book of Micah. And so if
you haven't been here, we're coming to the end. It's kind of sad that
that next week will be the last sermon in this series what
that also means we're gonna get a little more formal around here. If
you know what that means from the past I'd like for
more than four of you to engage that with me if you would but anyway,
we're gonna be Micah 7 today.
Micah 7 versus 11 through 17. So take your
copy of God's word turn there with me.
Micah 7 11 through 17
everyone loves a good rags to riches story, right?
You know like those movies where somebody down their
luck makes it the big time and has a lot of success things
like Pursuit of Happiness.
Or Slumdog Millionaire, maybe go
a little older Cinderella. It's kind of one of those or My
Generation Mr. Deeds actually was one anyway also
for you Hallmark movie fans. You might
recall this one plot line where the small
town waitress Waits on
the New York City lawyer who's car broke down
after he took a wrong turn and then Slayer that
evening happened to see her across the courtyard at the Christmas tree
lighting and and then he saw her
at the family's Bakery the next day and then he ends up
falling in love with her after cutting firewood with her
dad and then they end up buying
the bed and breakfast that they end up making scones together for
the rest. It's so beautiful.
I could get through it. Okay.
No, really. There's a
good movies because you already know the end right? So you already know what's coming which is actually
the point of the sermon by the way, but it's a whole others.
but
Seriously, though. There are also the real life stories like
bitty Mason.
Known as grandma Mason who was
born a slave in Mississippi, but one her freedom
in California in 1856 became one
of Los Angeles's first black land owners eventually
amassing a fortune through real estate.
Generously giving away to the poor and helping Finance the
founding of the city's first black church.
And so why do we love stories like that these Rags
to Riches? Why do we love those?
Because deep down we all know that things are not the
way they're supposed to be in the world right now.
Like we want we want to fix we want restoration. We
feel empty because creation is not as it once was
back in Genesis 1 and 2.
And creation is not the way it's going to be someday. And so
we want we want to be restored. We see the evil and
the wickedness in the world around us and we want it to be gone.
We also don't have that relationship with God like they had
back in the garden Adam and Eve Walking face to
face with God. We don't have that anymore. And so we
want restoration.
We want our lives to be perfect again because they're not
right now.
And so what do we do with that we?
We tend to try to manipulate and control things to get
them to be perfect for us.
At least our perception.
Or we turn to substances or to experiences to to
try to fill the emptiness that we feel in our
souls.
Actually what we're going to see today in Micah 7 is the
culmination of everything we long for.
It's it's the end of everything. We've been seen building
throughout Micah. We've seen it now today come to
this place where this is the restoration we see in long for
it's finally come.
We'll see it look at Micah 7 verses 11 through
17.
A day for the building of your walls in that
day the boundary shall be far extended.
In that day, they will come to you from a Syria
and the cities of Egypt from Egypt to the River from
sea to Sea Mountain to Mountain.
But the Earth will be desolate because of its inhabitants.
for the fruit of their deeds
Shepherd your people with your staff the flock of your inheritance
who dwell alone in a forest in the midst of
a garden land.
Let them graze and Bichon and Gilead as in the days of old.
As in the days when you came out of the land of Egypt, I will show them marvelous things.
The Nations shall see and be ashamed of all their
might they shall lay their hands on their mouths their ears shall
be deaf.
They shall lick the dust like a serpent like The Crawling things of
the Earth.
They shall come from trembling out of their strongholds.
They shall turn in dread to the Lord Our God and they
shall be in fear of you.
So he mentions that the at the start here a couple of times this day
he's talking about.
What's the same day? He's been talking about throughout the book that there's
there's a day coming when the Messiah King returns in
Victory. That's the day future for him still
future for us when Jesus returns victoriously.
So what he's talking about here is what will happen when that Kingdom
fully comes.
He's looking future. He's telling us to look future. What's
going to happen when God's kingdom fully comes.
Now again, as we've said throughout this series there's an already but not
yet nature to God's Kingdom.
Where in a sense since Jesus has come and
done all that he's done. It already has come for those
who have trusted in Jesus as their King
and savior have been brought into his kingdom. Yes, the kingdom
has come but it also has not yet
fully come.
Because God does not reign in every human heart yet.
And we look around and we see things look like
God doesn't Rule and Reign Over them. They're a mess.
It's broken. And so we know the kingdom has not yet fully come but
one day as we see here one day it will versus
8 through 10 promised last week the victories
coming.
God will win. This is what it's looking forward to
see what will happen when he does.
What will happen when the kingdom fully comes?
Here's what we see first. We see God flips the script.
God flips the script
It's actually what verse 11 indicates first. It's
that remember a Syria was
the nation that was pressing in on Judah at this time. And so they're
chewing up judah's land as they're pressing
into Jerusalem as the final prize.
They're taking all of judah's land. What once was
Judah once was Israel. They're taking it all and
all that's left is basically Jerusalem.
But one day this says that day.
Judas borders will be extended.
Judah will actually grow Judah will
actually expand its boundaries because so many
people are flowing into God's land.
So that's one flip. We see another flip. We see in verse 13.
Is that where these nations like Babylon and Assyria the
ones that were oppressing God's people Babylon in Assyria.
They were crazy wealthy. They seemed successful. They
would already be known as the most powerful Nations on
Earth. They seem like they had it all together, but they
would be made desolate it
says
They will be made desolate that word desolation has been used throughout Micah
right as a sign of judgment.
That God would make those who opposed him
a desolation empty.
But notice he says why it would be because of
its inhabitants.
for the fruit of their deeds
Basically, it just means you reap what you sow.
Sin has Eternal effects. God will not
just sweep it under the rug. There is a just God
there and so he's saying no I'm going to do something about that.
And for those who turn away from God.
Even if they seem successful, even if they seem wealthy all
put together everything is in order.
Even if they are that way if they turn away
from him, they will receive his judgment.
They'll be made a desolation. He says.
It's also what verses 16 and 17 allude to.
Where those who were once taunting Yahweh. Remember
last week verse 10, you're like, where's the Lord your God
like or we're coming in just mowing people down. No matter
what their God is. He's like, where's the Lord your God to come in
the taunting Yahweh taunting Judah.
Now it says they'll be made mute.
These wealthy powerful strong taunting
Nations will be made mute and
deaf. God will flip the script on them and
make them instead a riches to rag story.
That they thought they had it all together. They thought they were strong. They thought they
were where they should be and God makes them actually
bite the dust like the serpent in Genesis 3.
That's what it says here lick the dust like that where they're gonna be
trembling. They're gonna be afraid they're gonna be put underneath his heel.
That will finally see what they've been denying their entire lives that
there really is one true God out there. His name is Yahweh.
Now we can look at this from our side 2700 years
later and we can say
Well, that's that's trouble for them course a
Syria would be judged a course Babylon would be judged but but let's not
leave this in the Old Testament.
Let's bring this to today and ask the question.
Where do you stand in all of this?
because God is still just
God still says he's going to judge sin.
So you have to ask the question. Which direction is
your script going to be flipped here?
Because yes for for Judah.
Their script is going to be flipped and they were going to be expanded. They were going to have all the
safety and protection all those things that they needed. Yes, praise God
for that flip of a script that what we are
oppressed and downcast and Cast Away like that's gonna
be made in in all of God's ways righteous. Okay,
great.
But there's also the other way.
It's what we see here.
That you might think you have it all together.
You might think that you are doing exactly what
you and listen. You can be in church your entire life and be this way.
You're doing everything right? You got all the money you need you you got a
family put together the way you want it. You've got your business put together the way you want
it everything is exactly as you think it is and everybody looks at you like
you are the one that has the standard.
but if you are turning away from God
If you have stiff armed God and said I don't want anything to
do with you even though I'm going to be a religious person because it's gonna get me what I want.
But in your heart you've never said Jesus you are
my Lord. You are my king and my savior he is going
to judge you as well.
If you stand in opposition to God, he will bring judgment
in your life.
He flips the script.
when his kingdom comes
He exalts The Humble. He humbles the exalted.
It's what he does.
But there is something interesting about this.
Yes, he's going to judge the Nations that turn away from him. He's going to judge the
people that turn away from him.
But he hasn't fully forgotten the Nations, right?
You see this here?
He even draws the Nations.
at the same time
He also draws he's judging but he's
also drawing look at verse 12 again.
In that day again this day that's coming forward. They
will come to you.
Micah is saying this to God they will come to you from Assyria
the nation's oppressing them and the cities
of Egypt where they came from and from Egypt
to the River from sea to Sea from Mountain to Mountain basically from
the entire Earth. They will come
It's the same thing if you remember you've been tracking through this series with us that
God promised back in Micah chapter 4.
Where he was previewing the delivered city of Jerusalem up
on this mountain again, that was desolate.
He says no, it's actually gonna be redone. Here's what's going to happen. It's going to
look like this and so look at Chapter 4 verses 1 and 2.
It shall come to pass in the latter days again day
that the mountain of the house of the Lord
shall be established the highest of the mountains. It should be lifted up
above the hills and peoples.
Not just people like generic humans peoples. That's
Nations. That's languages that's people groups.
Shall flow to it.
and many nations shall come
and say come let us go up to the mountain of the Lord
to the house of the god of Jacob that he may teach us his path is ways.
We may walk in his paths.
So this idea that God is going to in the
end. Bring Nations to himself people to
himself is just the
Fulfillment of something. He's promised for the whole book the
whole time.
Even back to Genesis 12 when he chose Abraham and
he then chose Israel as well through Abraham.
He says I've blessed you to be a
blessing to the nation.
From the beginning of Israel's history. God said I've
blessed you to be a blessing to all the peoples of the Earth.
From the beginning God had a greater plan for his people
for the whole world.
That his Blessing was not exclusive to one family, but it
was actually for the Nations.
See his choice of Abraham was an end in itself.
Yes that God shows Abraham, but it was also at the
same time a means to an end.
That Abraham's election was for mission.
God shows Abraham for the purpose of blessing
all the Earth.
And that's that's part of the call he gave
to Abraham. So that means for us how does this work out for us as the
church? That means the church should not
see the mission of God as an add-on to
its work.
I think for so long many Christians have seen this
is what we do. We come to church we study
the Bible we sing we do our Sunday school thing
and that's good. Just the mission is those people over
there those superhero Christians? Keep it over there. Just don't
get in our way and we'll support you but just this is this
is what we do. That's what you guys do.
but actually
The mission is part of what God called Abraham to
do. It's part of what he's called us into it's
what Isaiah heard from God Isaiah. 49:6.
God says to him. It's too light a
thing that you should be my servant to raise up just the tribes of Jacob and
bring back The Preserve of Israel. I will make you as a
light for the Nations.
That my salvation May reach to the end of the Earth.
What he says to Isaiah is not enough that he
would get Israel back.
Great. Yes, but it's not enough. He's
after the Nations, too.
It's all over Micah. It's all over the prophets.
It's in jesus' Great Commission mandate at
the end of Matthew 28 to make disciples of
all Nations at the end of Acts. 1:8 Jerusalem,
Judea Samaria. The ends of the Earth. This is
from the very beginning. It's what God has had
in mind for his people.
To go to the Nations and it all culminates in this.
It culminates in what?
the Apostle John saw
in the Book of Revelation
So we're looking at this day right in Micah. We're looking at the day that Messiah
returns John got a glimpse of
what it looks like.
On the other side of this thing. He said I here's what I see. Here's what I'm
seeing happen in heaven right now that
it's going to be that way forever.
John got a glimpse into that. We're in Revelation
5 9 and 10. He heard them sing this song to
Jesus worthy. Are you to take the scroll
to open its seals for you were slain by your
blood you ran some people for God from every tribe
and language and people and nation and you've made them a
kingdom and Priests to our God and they shall
reign on the Earth.
Continuous chapter 7 verses 9
and 10. He looked again and he saw this picture of the throne room
of Heaven. He said I looked and behold a great multitude. No
one could number from every nation from all
tribes and peoples and languages standing Before the Throne before the
lamb clothed in white robes palm branch in their hands crying out
with a loud voice salvation Belongs To Our God
who sits on the throne to the lamb.
This is what heaven looks like.
This is God's heart for the nations from
the very beginning. He's always had that mindset.
He's always been drawing people including us.
Who are not ethnic Israel?
He's he's drawing Nations to himself.
And it culminates as Micah looked forward as
John got to see culminates in a representative from every
nation at the end.
This is what God's heart shows us.
It's not just about those people. It's about.
The Nations not just about us. It's about them as well.
There's one more piece of Micah 7.
That will happen when God fully inaugurates his kingdom. He will
Shepherd his people.
It's the last piece of this is that he will Shepherd his people God Shepherds
his people.
And we see this in verse 14 in Micah 7.
This is Micah praying to God. He says Shepherd your
people with your staff.
The flock of your inheritance who dwell alone in a forest
in the midst of a garden land let them graze in
Bichon and Gilead as in the days of old.
another flipping of the script here
where Micah prayed that God would Shepherd his people
out of the ashes into the beauty.
because remember
in Micah's day God's remnant of believer's we're in
a really tough spot.
A serious pressing in they were surrounded
out there by fertile ground, but they were living
in scrub basically.
Because that word you saw it there who dwell
alone in a forest that word Forest don't think the Hobbit like
lush green forestry. That's not it.
It's actually more like West Texas scrub.
That's the image we get from this word which
brings with it this idea of lonely deprived.
Empty, there's nothing.
That's why Micah intercedes here and prays asking God
to restore the lusciousness of the
pastures of of these cities Bichon and Gilead which
were right on the other side of Jordan River. That was the entry
into the promised land for God's people.
So he's like God give us that back. We enjoyed that
for many years right off the bat how milk flowing honey
flowing like this was incredible look at
the wheat and look at all this stuff that we can have God restored
again.
We have scrub now.
Restore us God.
But here's what that gives us a glimpse into.
part of God's judgment on his people
as his people turned away from him and
turned to idols and all these other things part of God's judgment was to
turn the promised land into a wasteland.
What they had was so beautiful and nice and they said all right,
but we want this stuff over here God instead of you and he just said, all right,
here's what this is gonna look like.
turned into a wasteland
yet.
God will one day reset that
promise.
To bring back Beauty bring back joy, and he'll do
it. He says through the image of a shepherd.
Right see that verse 14 this image of a Shepherd. It's been
all throughout Micah.
If you remember back to chapter 2.
God said, he's the king going out before his
people and he's Gathering them like a sheep
in a fold.
If he's the standard bear in front of his people and then
in verse four of chapter 5 that was The Prophecy
of the Messiah coming and he's going to be a Shepherd standing in
shepherding in the strength of the Lord his flock.
And we know both of those point to Jesus.
But what does this reveal about God this idea of a Shepherd if that's
how he's going to bring about?
this day
What does it reveal about him? What do we see God's heart
here. Well first we see that his heart is to provide.
for his flock
He turns the barren Wasteland into a beautiful
pasture land again.
Takes Beauty out of the ashes. He provides
for his people but it also shows he covers his people
with protection. That's the image of the staff.
That God possesses this powerful authority to protect
his people.
So many people love Psalm 23 quoted at
all kinds of things.
But verse 4 says even though I walk through the valley the shadow of death.
I will fear no evil for you or with me your rod
and your staff they comfort me.
That's how it's comforting is because I know God you can protect me
with those things as a sheep. The shepherd would
lean on that Shepherds Authority and
ability to protect them from wolves and to keep
them safe.
Same thing.
Shepherd your people with your staff
with protection
But then there's a third aspect the shepherd.
Portrays this intimacy with his people here.
Did you see what Micah says in verse 14? He says Shepherd your
people God.
the flock of your inheritance
There's a there's an intimacy there's a personal connection
that he is longing to have restored again.
Like they lost in the garden and Genesis 1 and
2 Adam had it Genesis 3, they lost it what he's
now long before God. Give us your presence again. We want
to be back with you again want to be your people again?
well
again, we're looking forward to a day.
When that becomes a reality.
which John saw Revelation 21 verse 3
he heard a loud voice saying Behold The Dwelling Place of
God is with man.
He will dwell with them. They will be his people God himself
will be with them as their God. That's
what he's longing for. Is this restoration of the
relationship face to face with the holy God. That's what he wants. He
Longs that Shepherd to be with them.
And so as we come to this point in spite of all the
Carnage and the mess we've seen throughout the
Book of Micah, right?
It's just it's been so hard to watch people turn away and
turn away and be judged and brought back and turn
away and the cycle of Doom and judgment coming back.
over and over again
yet.
Is this not a beautiful picture?
Of what God is going to bring with him one day.
as the king returns
to restore all things where he makes his people
the perfect rags to
riches story.
Is this not a glorious Grace To Us
Church?
That this is what God is bringing.
Out of the mess the Micah was in out of the mess that we live in
God is going to restore.
So, what should we do now?
What do we do now?
Because no matter what Nostradamus says this thing
hasn't happened yet.
Right. This is still coming.
The full restoration the full inauguration the
kingdom is still future. So what do we do until then? How
do we respond to this knowing? This is coming. What do we
do now?
First Trust God's plan
You got to just trust God's plan and all
of this.
Because think Micah never got to see the results of this, did he?
Micah in fact got exiled here in just
a few years after he writes this.
He died actually before they got it so he didn't get to see any of
this.
He never got to see that God would come through for his people. He never
got to see this restoration was going to happen that God would
flip the enemy on its head so he had to trust.
He had to have faith in his God in this Lord
of all the Earth that God you're gonna do this in your time in your
way.
That's what we see in the book of Hebrews chapter 11 over and over
and over again, but specifically for those who died without
seeing what God promised.
Listen to Hebrews 11:13. These all
died in faith not having received the
things promised.
But having seen them and greeted them from afar having acknowledged
that they were strangers and Exiles on the
Earth.
See, that's how Micah could get there.
That's how Micah could trust it's because he know this was not
his home.
Even if it was perfect, even if everything was exactly as they
would want it in Judah it still wasn't home.
He was longing for something more.
And yet in that faith.
He was able to see beyond.
I mean at least 2700 years. We don't know when Jesus come
back, but it's 2,700 years later than he was living. So he was able
to see at least that far and he's able to kind of greet it
from afar and saying God, alright, it feels
like we're already there.
I can see it. I can know it's real. I know you're going to
do this and so I can trust you and I can almost live in it
now.
Greet it from afar.
So his faith was in the promise of God.
You and I must have that same faith.
That same Forward Thinking mentality.
We must trust that the Lord is coming back
one day, right?
That this isn't it.
I hope this isn't it, right.
We must trust that he is coming back. We must trust that even
among those who are opposed to Yahweh today
that even some of those will come to believe.
Remember Saul wrote two thirds of the New Testament
right? He he was clearly opposed to All Things Yahweh.
and yet
God saved him.
So God's going to do that with some.
We must trust that the evil and wickedness. We see
around us every day.
That God's gonna do something about that.
That he eventually will bring this to
pass that it won't be swept under the rug.
We've got to trust that God's gonna do it and his time in his way. We got to trust that
God's Gonna satisfy our souls as we deny ourselves are
the things of the world and we turn to him. We've got to trust that
that's going to be satisfying.
We have to trust him.
See we can rewrite or try to rewrite our own future.
We can try to manipulate things to benefit ourselves to make
it the way we want it to but we need to
do what God is asking us to do right now and just trust
him.
Not try to control manipulate make it this way and fix this and do it
this way. No, just trust him.
His future plan not our ideas on what
that plan should be.
Remember the bumper sticker God is my co-pilot.
No, God is your pilot you sit in that seat you sit
in the back. Don't even sit up the next day you sit in the back and just
let him fly for you. Right if God's your co-pilot. I
mean you're flying the plane. You don't want that.
You want his plan his time his way.
Now I know listen that's hard to do in the Darkness.
It's hard to see when you can't see I get that.
But that's why Micah is such a great example.
Because it was as bad as it could ever get for June for
Micah and Judah.
It was as bad as anything. It was way past
anything we experienced today.
and yet
still trusted
he still trusted never wavered.
You might never see God's promises come to pass in your lifetime.
You might be asking and praying and longing for
justice in this situation that situation you might never see it in your
lifetime.
But that doesn't mean that God's not on his throne.
It doesn't mean that God's not good.
He just got a different timeline than you do.
He's going to take care of the situation. So trust him.
Let him do the task. Let him
do his work. Let him do what he's going to do what he's promised
to do. Let him show himself strong.
And have faith Trust.
But even as you do that.
It doesn't give you license to be lazy.
That you have nothing to do. I'm just trusting God. I'm gonna
sell the couch play Xbox like no, that's not what we're talking about.
Because what it might could do.
What's verse 14 said he'd do.
He interceded for others.
He prayed.
He went to the Lord and pray at minimum.
Whatever situation we're facing we can pray.
Because Micah has been standing by himself for
the whole book.
He's standing on God's side against everybody else
and he's like, it's like God. I feel like I'm
alone here and and I'm speaking your truth. Nothing
is happening. Nothing is changing God. Why is
this not working?
And he could easily be tempted in that moment to look down
on everybody else.
Like God I'm seeking you. I'm trying to seek you. They're not even close. They're
not even trying.
Something to look down on them.
That's not his attitude is it?
His attitude is to pray and have a heart
broken for them. He Longs for restoration for
them.
They don't deserve it.
But he's saying God restore them.
He loved them too much to let them go. He's done it through the whole book. God.
Don't let them go. Bring them back. My heart is still towards
them. So God restore them.
I know it may feel like you have.
Nothing, you can do about the situation. You're facing in your
life.
Everything's falling apart around you and you feel like I can't do
anything about this. There's never nothing you
can do about it.
There's always something you can do about the situation.
In fact, it's the most important thing you can do.
That's why one of our values as a church is desperate dependence.
That we know we're trusting God to do
the real work in this thing, right? Because only God
can change a heart.
Only God can fix a situation Only God
Can restore a relationship. You can't do
those things. You can't get in there and change it. It's got to
be God's work. That's why we pray.
That's why I send a letter to our widows and widowers every Monday thing here
pray for these things because I need them. You need them. We need
them to carry these needs to God and we're
not praying to get God to do something for us like a vending
machine. Here's a dollar. Give us this we want God to
do something that only he can take the credit for
And we need him to do the work that we can't do anything about.
So we lean on him we need him.
You can do that you can intercede for yourself. Of course. Yes, but
you can intercede for your family for your spouse for
your coworker for your neighbor for your nation for your
your friends. You can intercede on behalf
of them praying for Restoration in God's
time God's way.
But then there's also this we talk about restoration. Yes, we want.
That in our lives, but but when was the last time you actually prayed
for someone to be restored spiritually. When
was the last time you prayed for an unbeliever to know
Jesus?
Remember a couple years ago. We did the Hoosier one thing.
Are you praying that God would which is the most important restoration by
the way that God would restore someone spiritually.
Save them reach into their sin and draw them
out to righteousness. It's saving their soul from
death.
When was the last time you did
that commit to praying for someone to know Jesus?
Because again if this day hasn't come
yet, we know God's not done drawing people to himself
yet.
Still be more that will come.
Which leads to the last thing we should do now?
In light of this future Kingdom that's coming. We should proclaim
the gospel.
Proclaim the gospel Proclaim this good news.
Tell of God's salvation.
You may recall Romans 10:13. It says everyone who calls
on the name of the Lord will be saved.
But listen to verse 14 and then verse 15 how then will
they call on him in whom they've not believed?
How are they to believe in him of whom they've never
heard?
And how are they to hear without someone preaching?
And how are they to preach unless they are sent.
As it is written how beautiful are the feet of those who preach
the good news.
What do we say every time we end to worship Gathering here at Henderson Hills?
You are sent.
This is what you're sent to do if you've ever wondered.
Yes, love people all the things but but this is what you're sent to
do right to proclaim the gospel to preach the
good news that Jesus lived died and resurrected in our
place. That is the best news. But here's the thing about good
news, you know, if there's good news, then there's comparatively bad
news.
And that's what we saw in Micah 7 right that
sin that causes desolation that brings God's judgment
in your life. And so listen if you are sitting here today or
watching that you are you're still in your sin, if
that's you as you've not turned to Jesus. You've not given him your
whole heart and life then that is where you are.
You're in the bad news, you're going to receive judgment. You're going to be desolate.
Which is why we as Believers must be good
news people.
Where we are declaring there's a way out of your emptiness.
There's a way out of this Brokenness and it's
found in Jesus.
That's what we Proclaim and declare and believe in sing. It's found
in Jesus, but remember
Someone cannot call on salvation unless they
believe Jesus is the way.
And they cannot believe.
Unless they've heard that.
And they cannot hear that unless someone tells them.
You are sent right like that's that's the whole point of that.
It's what's beautiful. Jesus eats beautiful are
the feet of those who bring good news. That's you and me we can
be that.
Now, let me be clear. It's up to God to save right? It's not
up to us. We're still reformed here. Like this is God's deal. He's saving
we're just vessels of his Mercy. He
calls us to do what Psalm 96 says that as
we go in our lives. We declare his glory among
the Nations His Marvelous Works among all the peoples. We
say among the Nations the Lord Reigns,
like that's our task now is to
go declare who he is. And again, we don't know who he's Gonna
Save. We don't know how many he's Gonna Save but check
this out Micah 7 said that when God's kingdom comes he
will save some
He's going to save.
Some will call on him some will come to his Mountain.
So that means for us we can have confidence that
as we go tell of God's salvation as we do go
and declare the gospel some will believe
Even if we're terrible at sharing the gospel God still
going to save even those who appear to be opposed
to it right now.
The nation's a Syria Babylon some will
come.
Is just the way God works.
He works through US plus there's this.
Jesus said in Matthew 24:14 this gospel. The
kingdom will be proclaimed throughout the whole world as a testimony
to All Nations, and then the end will come.
In other words, this is part of the conclusion of the story.
Because you know, he didn't poof you out to Heaven as soon as
you believed right he left you here.
And he left you here for a reason and that reason is not
merely to survive until he gets here or to hold
up in in this cult like building that
you're gonna just get away from the world. That's not what he's called us to
he left you here to include you on his mission.
He has graciously chosen you to use
you as his Global ambassador.
Which means you can pray you can give you can
support and encourage others to go. You can go yourself, but
you are an ambassador as that just like
Abraham was blessed to be a blessing to others.
You are saved to carry that same gospel to
others.
Bless you with the gospel to be a blessing to All
Nations.
But hear me you won't do that. I won't do
that.
Only if I'm transformed by
what Jesus has done in my life will I see
that as worth it?
Well, I will I pay the cost needed to make that a
reality in my life. Will I walk the Hard
Road? It's going to take to care the gospel. Carry the gospel to this
people group only if I see him as
worth it. If I desire more than anything else to see
him as glorious to the ends of the Earth to see
him as glorious the ends of my street. The only one I
see him as that and I desire his worship to be
going to the ends of the Earth. That's the only reason I'll do it.
Because that's what's coming on the day. He returns, right?
on that day, Micah 7
On that day, the Nations will
worship.
The mountain will be raised up. God will be
seen as glorious.
That's what is coming. And so now
we just get the privilege of playing a small part of seeing
that Kingdom Come even in small forms today.
That's what's coming one day. And so we get the opportunity. John
Piper said it well like missions exist because worship doesn't
There's places. Jesus is not being worshiped. And so we
carry the gospel to them in hopes that they will.
prayerfully that they will
and so as you
as you
prayerfully entrust your future to the Lord.
Say God, whatever you want. Whatever your deal is, you're playing not
mine. I entrust my future to you as you do that.
Commit to carrying his gospel to your neighborhood to
the Nations to your family.
For his glory because he is worth it
Church.
He's worth it. Not just in here when it's really
easy to say. Yes glory to God praise the Lord and we're
going to sing here in a little while and it's going to be yes, praise God. It's
worth it even out there.
He is worth it when it gets hard when it gets tricky
and people push back he's worth it.